i imagine that you're in the doghouse
right now people have been in quarantine
and they've been like taking up baking
or
knitting or whatever it is but you've
been working on this space of yours
it's almost like a little vip area you
can see everything that's going on
see everybody having an awesome time and
you know
kind of just a bird's eye view a whole
joint it's incredible do you spend most
of your time in there
a lot of it man yeah it's uh man it
gives me a place to kind of
get away it's kind of like an office
slash man cave slash garage slash
everything so yeah it's a it's a
one-stop shop
that's awesome well i mean the music is
doing you well
fire and brimstone deluxe has been a
nice thing to have over the past year
[Music]
the hard days is a song that we actually
wrote a few years back
because i think a lot of people thought
you know we wrote the song
for what's going on in the world right
now that's not the case
but this is a special song man
well we've definitely all had hard days
with the lockdown
but brantley is thankful for the extra
time with his family
considering you know the real hard times
that people have been going through
it's affected all of us i think in some
ways
it was good it made us slow down and you
know just appreciate the small things
around us
for those of us that have kids you know
it gave us an opportunity to
be at home and share time with them that
we wouldn't have been able to otherwise
my wife married me with the idea in mind
that i'd be gone a lot
and i haven't been so i know she's ready
to go